in the unionist heartlands they don't
want a border between them and great
britain
boris has created a brexit that's
specifically for england this isn't
the brexit that anybody voted for
but the east-west sea border was
established to avoid a north-south land
border
we put the genie back in the bottle
who in their right mind would even think
about opening that bottle
julianne represents working-class
unionists
she's concerned that brexit checks are
pushing up the price of food in northern
ireland
representing an area that ranks number
two with the highest levels of multiple
deprivation
that has food banks popping up
everywhere and anywhere where there's a
great dependency on food bikes in this
constituency
that worries me and i think that the the
british government in particular who
walked us into this situation who are
responsible for this situation
need to pull up their shocks roll up
their sleeves and treat this for the
crisis that it is
but border communities say the protocol
offers northern ireland
exclusive access to the eu market
and to the uk market i'll throw these
over and i'll come back and unlock the
gate
damien is already seeing the benefits
and he can't believe that anyone would
want to walk away from this deal
come on girls when we sell them for beef
i expect to get four pounds a kilo for
them that has never happened in my
lifetime
milk is uh is thriving on this island
it's an all island business it flows 30
or 40
across the border every single day the
fishermen here
are earning double what their
counterparts in england
scotland and wales are because they have
access to the european market
they said it would be easy to avoid a
hard border here where northern ireland
and the republic meet
but five years after the uk voted to
leave the european union
they still haven't found a solution and
brexit still causing tension in the
peace process
when it comes to northern ireland the uk
and eu
remain at loggerheads but this isn't
just about politics
it's about livelihoods and people want
practical solutions
not more words david blevins sky news on
the northern ireland border